Congressman what's your reaction to
members of your own are you calling for
your resignation
142 people ask for me to resign
we are here today to say that if George
Santos does not come to the voters then
the voters will come to Mr Santos and
you don't get away with being the
biggest fraud in modern American
political history
and we will work day and night to hold
you accountable
George Santos
is a national story he's a national
embarrassment
we have never seen anything like this
before
so we are looking to get Congress to
expel and the first step to do that
is we need to have a United District we
need to go to Congress United our
Republican leaders are democratic
leaders need to join hands
and say we are we want him to be
resigned but if he won't reside we want
to be very clear we will push
to have Congress expel him I find the
story troubling because
um you know we're doing everything we
can to help our community and help those
in need and there are so many in need
and yet we just find ourselves being
wronged by the people who are supposed
to be lifting our community up and
supposed to make a vow to protect us
with integrity and they're not doing
that and you know it takes the voice of
so many kids who are just trying to
learn about democracy and trying to
exist in a world where they can make a
difference and yet we run into stories
like this and it derails our efforts and
it's horrible and it's very
disheartening he took he found the way
and he made it work for him at the end
of the date he was elected afford the
man the opportunity to see if he can
deliver on the promises that he
delivered 142 000 people voted for him
right
they saw something about him they like
this is him lying and running from his
constituents he says that he's not going
to listen to the congressman telling him
I don't listen to politicians telling me
to leave he said I'll listen to my 142
constituents that voted for me well he's
not counting the people like me who did
not vote for him and now all the people
who did vote for him that no longer want
him as their representative
so I would like to see him running with
his pants on fire and out of out of this
country even maybe they should prosecute
him in Brazil for the checks that he
stole and the money that he was using
that was not his